all right
taylor taylor where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
los angeles south central yeah
tell me about your family growing up you
had both your with your parents or no
oh no no
i they raised me but i decided to leave
home early
what age did you leave so when what age
did you leave home
about 15 15. what was going on at home
that you left so early really everything
was actually all right it's just like
that
i struggled with the streets really
there's a lot it's a lot of temptation
you know like
drugs prostitution there's
i was interested in a lot of things and
guys were
another big you know
i thought i was growing i wanted to be
an adult
i wanted to do what i want to do at 15
even i'm 15.
yeah so where did that lead you when you
to the streets really i
was homeless for actually
a long time like a year and a half and
then i started
making money on the side like you know
with guys prostitution and stuff like
that
here and there and i started getting
rooms and stuff
did you have a pimp actually
no i was a renegade but i did write
assistant pimp
but mostly running game that's right
mostly renegade but i was i did run into
a
couple
yeah how how is working
figaro street different with or without
a pimp
with the pimp there's
some type of protection out there really
you can carry knives
mace or whatever or maybe even little
you know
guns if you have them but
that's not always going to guarantee
that you'll be safe
so it's always good to have extra
protection around
and hold you now i'm 20
20. yeah
are drugs a part of your life at all
excuse me are you are drugs a part of
your life
yeah unfortunately crystal meth
yeah when did that start for you
15 same age yeah
i think that's let's start it do you
think
yeah crystal meth kind of
ramps up your sex drive right yeah
so then it makes the whole thing kind of
easier yeah
a lot easier actually and you become
bold fearless and full of energy you're
very energetic
yeah i've heard that a lot yeah
and today you're working with a fan for
without without
how did you break away from from the
last pimp you were with
just i don't know
change the what's what block your own or
whatever
and try to change your look a little bit
because if you're out there working you
get recognized
but i guess i'd get lucky
no kids no
you've been in love before have you been
loved before
no you're young though
dear friends very few
that i will call friends yeah it's kind
of hard with this lifestyle right
right
do you find it hard to find people that
you trust they
are yeah
a lot of hustlers
the tricks the the pimps the other girls
everyone even the cops sometimes right
right
where do you stay now are you just motel
the motel yeah
yeah it's a mommy just motel and you
you'll work through the night
yeah the crystal meth makes it easier
right you can stay up
it does
have you had bad things happen to you
out there a lot of the girls have
stories of things that are happening
what kind of stuff has happened i've had
tricks tried to kidnap me
i've had them like try to like abuse me
while
we have sex like you know like it's
it's just a lot and i've had pimps hop
out on me and
and try to kidnap me as well and
um even if even their
hoes their prostitutes
try to recruit me and stuff and then
like if i don't come home with them or
whatever
they want to fight me or spray me with
pepper spray stuff like that
it's such a crazy lifestyle
everything from the you know the dangers
the hours the
the type of people you're interacting
with i mean you must
stand back sometimes and look at what
you're doing
yeah did you have dreams of doing
something when you were you
i mean you're still very young but do
you have dreams of doing anything with
your life
yeah but i don't i don't think i could
do it now for some reason like
i don't know a lot of the girls tell me
they're addicted to
the lifestyle fast money and all that
yeah
would be hard to put it down and do
something different it's very hard to
i've tried
i took myself to rehab before
i was clean for over a year and a half
but
it's always something it's always
temptation
as soon as you're short on money it
becomes like the easy way to get it
yeah do you remember your first time
picking up a trick
yeah i was so scared i was nervous but
of course somebody taught me the basics
but it went smooth my first time
and then eventually you get over the
hurdle of doing it and then it becomes
easier yeah
eventually it'll become regular
how much money do you make in a night
usually usually
it will take about 600 maybe seven
nine on the good night right
are you saving money yeah i'm learning
how to save money basically
like you know put like a little more
than half of
it you know you're starting spending on
the rooms and
yeah stuff like that
does your family know you're doing it no
but i'm afraid now yeah don't go on
youtube
yeah you might find out it'll be all
right
you get depressed angry like that
often yeah
what was your relationship like with
your dad
my father he
was a very demanding person like he
he's a neat freak everything has to be
spotless
and and he come home from work he opened
the door he has to smell the aroma of
pine star in
in you know but that was all right
but you got a dad in your life yeah i
did have my father
that's rare it is the majority of the
girls that are doing this kind of work
don't have a father didn't have dads
around i know but
i don't i i guess i wanted attention
from
other men other people
i i got to thank for standing out
do you think that that's the attraction
for girls doing this kind of work is
that they're just looking for
the attention from men yeah and in the
money and the dream they want to please
the guy
their pen the trick whatever just to get
what they want out of it
whether it's money sex or whatever yeah
or to be taken care of
or just to be left in a way i guess
or less yeah it becomes like a
substitute for a romantic relationship
right
yes
how has this changed your view of men
you think
guys can be full of [ __ ] man sometimes
it can be but you know
some people got to open their eyes
sometimes to really get to know who the
person is before they decide to
jump head first into a situation that
they can't get out of or it's very hard
to get out of
yeah a lot of your tricks are uh
are married you think yeah
yes it's hard for you to have faith in
in men after seeing how many men are
cheating on their wives
seriously i don't want to get married
no no
then you kind of get desensitized to how
dangerous this life is and you just
just go out and do it again yeah right
because you know
like any any night you get kidnapped
robbed
worse killed killed
what do you think most people don't
understand about girls that do this kind
of work
we're not always doing it just for the
money
maybe we need something like like or or
like
maybe it is for me or we use it for like
school or
you know trying to get back on our feet
you know so we won't be sleeping in the
cardboard box or something or
tents yeah you're just trying to survive
right survival that's all it is
because really i don't i don't pay for
my drugs i don't have to
i know certain people and they just you
know
i used to take care of myself really and
to try my best to look human still
you're regulars yeah
so sometimes i won't have to walk sick
they just come to my room
they just call you and meet you
do you have a dream of maybe one of your
tricks one day
taking you away from all this and making
your life a little better and easier
i do oh i do
i do not wait for it you're 20.
what mistakes have you made that you've
learned from
in doing this get
my money first
yep i oh i always used to forget that
like the first few let's say
weeks i yeah
oh i was so angry when they began
oh man i threw a brick out of chick's
coffin
so yeah yeah yeah your money first
how do you think you've changed from
your five years of doing this
i believe i've matured a whole lot more
and
yeah yeah
i grew up a lot it's longer
can you see that you deserve a better
life than than this
yes and i really
i really do believe i do but it's hard
to get out of this
it really is yeah but somewhere there
are guys
probably not driving up and down
figueroa street on a friday or saturday
night that
but there are guys out there that will
treat you with respect and
help you achieve your dreams and doing
things like that
yeah i have to get out of a way for
figaro
to meet them you type of a guy yeah no
it's like it's like a moth to flame you
just keep
a lot of these girls just spend decades
there
yes i see some old prostitutes that you
see when i was little little
i remember this lady
what kind of things does a girl need to
know when she's doing this kind of stuff
you got to make sure the door opens from
the inside always
because they will try to trap your ass
in there
take you wherever and do whatever to you
and take your phone and take everything
you got so you will have no type of
communication with the outside world and
you'd
be locked up trapped
ate killed whatever
it's very dangerous
are you lonely are you lonely
yeah yeah i'm lonely even though you're
having sex like 10 times a night you're
you're still lonely right sex has
nothing to do with it that's right
that's right especially that kind right
right sex is a tool it should be used as
a tool
if feelings are involved or are you
trying to
get there
but we use it to get our money
survival
and you get requests that are a little
risky from your
your clients yeah
and there is no way in hell like like
they're back are you serious
no next right
ain't no way
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's considering doing something
like this
choose a different career
anything with
do you this working without a pimp
it depends on what kind of pants yeah
there's always many different kinds
right that's what people they maybe
don't understand that the pimp is not a
pimp there's so many different types
exactly you gotta be careful what kind
of pimp you
you meet and hook up with her exactly
most of them approach you as boyfriends
yeah
luckily for me because i have seen a few
of the ladies out there that has
some of the meanest girl the pimps i've
ever seen in my life
like wow like that's how you
treat her and then you send her out here
looking terrible
beat up bruises black eyes
busted lip swollen like i'm like what
the [ __ ]
no why do you think most girls don't
leave that situation
because they're afraid regulating their
terror
either they're in love with the guy or
they're
scared for their life probably both at
the same time
yeah that's that's what i see exactly
it's a shame that more more of these
girls don't see
that they deserve better yeah it's like
they think that's
maybe it's because of the relationship
they had with their dads or something
like that
yeah that's what they blame it on
most of them i'm trying to make sense of
it because it just seems so ridiculous
that
why would you tolerate that but they
keep running back to it
maybe they liked me and just wanted to
be grown when they were younger didn't
listen to their father
you know my i listened but i mean i
heard him but i didn't listen it's a big
difference to hearing listening
my dad used to tell me if you listen to
me you will have an easier life
if not it would be hard i didn't listen
my life is hard i struggle every day
every single day whether it's paying for
my room eating or
or going to get clothes or whatever you
know necessities i need
i should have listened but unfortunately
i didn't listen to him i didn't graduate
high school
i dropped out in 11th grade
the most important thing you've learned
in your 20 years
this type of lifestyle is not for
everybody
it's not
i had dreams of becoming an actress when
i was younger
um i think i could do that now my looks
are changing
because of the drugs of course and
because of the stress
and everything else
oh yeah streets don't love me
taylor i hope you figure out a way out
me too you're so you're very young you
can you've got 20 years ahead of you
all right thank you so much for talking
with me i wish you the best of luck
thank you very much you're welcome
you